MATTHEWS HAS NOT SCORED AGAINST.
BACK TO OF THE YEAR.
POKED THROUGH
IT COMES TO THE LINE WHERE STÜT
LEFTY.
AND STÜTZLE, PERFECT PASS ON
YOUR OFF
BRADY TKACHUK.VER. THE DEFLECTI
WORKING UP HIGH.
DOWN
HALL.
SCORES!DEFLECTION.
GOT HIS STICK RIGHT OUT IN FRONT
ALMOMO
SCORES! IT IS COMING
HE'S NOT TRYING TO GET IT PAST
FORSBERG.
HE'S TRYING TO GET IT TO THE
OTHER SIDE BRODIE.
MARNER.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
BACK.
NYLANDER WILL TAKE IT.rn ] BOBB.
LOOK AT THE CONFIDENCE.
IT KEEPS ON
BUNTING.
BACKHANDED GOAL.
MITCH MARNER WENT TO THE NET.
THED THE STICK OF HOLDING AND
ALL KINDS OF TRAFFIC AND  IN FR!
OFF FORSBERG RIELLY.
H
KALLGREN MAKES THE STOP!DANO GO!